let's go over the problem again we want
to build an application with a list of
cats and when you click on the cat in
the list they will display in the cat
viewing area here and what's more the
number for the number of clicks should
always reflect the number of the current
cat we're going to go through this right
now and figure out what should belong to
the model the view or views and the
octopus first let's identify the model
and the view portions of the following
things choose whether they belong in the
model or the view the clickable list of
cats here the current cat display and
the array of cat objects which is
driving all of this